look at Teddy oh look at that oh my God
he bent them so hard just now
here we go day two Disney
[Music]
all right so for the first event that
we're doing today we get to do a tasting
of all of the food that they have here
at the Food and Wine Festival at
California Adventure and oh my God
everything went so delicious I cannot
wait to taste it all right so these are
all of the selections that we get to
enjoy everything looks so beautiful so
delectable so ah amazing wait where's
the child oh right there okay with Luca
oh with Isaac yes are you excited yeah
foodie here yes I am super excited I
actually did some work for Disney where
I documented all this stuff yeah now you
actually get to try it yes so last year
around this time last year is when Casey
was working with Disney plus to do some
video stuff and now we actually get to
be here and eat it
oh look at what we got
I'm eating this barbecue pulled pork
sandwich this looks like Empanada Isaac
just brought these over there's also
some signature drinks and this is the
space this is really cool so it's a
Hyperion theaters right here California
Adventure and they have this like area
here for like private locations this is
usually the queue or the Hyperion
theater
it feels like morning I know I had such
a late night super late night but we
made it out yes we made it for the food
that's why we had to come while we're
here
oh what else did you bring baby nachos
delicious we're gonna go this is our
breakfast can you believe that delicious
breakfast actually I didn't even tell
you guys but Luca last night woke up
during a World of Color was awakened
because it was so loud he kept like
trying to go back to sleep and then
waking up and then go back going back to
sleep and finally by the time we got to
the hotel he was like wide awake and we
got back to the hotel like around 1 30.
didn't go to sleep until 3 A.M oh my God
literally running all five hours of
sleep because we woke up at eight crazy
crazy crazy boy but that's just how it
is you know things are gonna be out of
the norm no routine the sleep's gonna be
all over the place so right now he's
napping
[Music]
oh my goodness how cute look Mickey
shaped Snickers macaroon oh my God that
sounds amazing there's Donald Duck Chef
Donald
[Music]
look who's awake Luca Luca who's awake
look at who's awake
all right so Luca woke up from his map
and I'm feeding him some mac and cheese
and he's watching all the kids run
around here and he's like freaking out
because he loves watching kids play like
he wants to join the party but he can't
run yet he like he's still like a wobbly
Walker but he's so eager to go and play
with all the kids here it's so cute
[Music]
just running around
all right
do you hear me
[Music]
Blackberry lavender lemonade
oh that's tart it's really yummy and
then we got the other tacos
yum yum yeah that looks really good
let's dice the pineapple does it taste
like real al pastor the flavors are
pretty close
[Music]
the blueberry pancake
I'm five years old I don't know how to
drink from a cup there we go but you
can't get all the Crispies with the with
the straw actually
that's actually really good it's not too
sweet exactly what I like all right and
next we have this artichoke pizzetta you
came to I heart artichokes so this one
the whole family will get to enjoy this
looks so cute and delicious artichokes
Pizza hello
you're nothing dispenser look at that
ready for the next one you're such a dad
I love it good job just wants to go with
you everything
it's so crazy
[Music]
very nice very Hawaiian no it's very La
it's called La style oh sorry sorry so
it's a glazed barbecue pork belly
very Hawaiian
it should be Hilo Style
you got a joke
[Music]
barbecue pork Oh barbecue pork sorry
there you go
[Music]
very tasty
that's the tiniest bite is that a bite
[Music]
that was his first character uh meeting
finally out of all the characters we've
seen he's always asleep he's like who's
this like do I know you I know you
excuse me
what is that look at him I'm so excited
he loves seeing kids play that's his
favorite thing all right so I am now
back in the room today was really fun
but super tiring because of the fact
that I only had five hours of sleep last
night it's almost 9 p.m now Casey and
Isaac decided to stay in the park for a
little longer so I brought Luca with me
and we're just gonna wind down and Hope
this kid will go to sleep soon because I
am wiped out I'm so tired but I wanted
to show you guys when I got into the
room I saw something on the desk and I
was like wait a minute
Pandora
what is this so let's open it oh my
goodness Disney and Pandora what do we
have
oh cute it's a mini charm oh my goodness
on a necklace oh my gosh this is so cute
wow
what do you think Luca you like it
look it's a mini necklace oh so spoiled
I know I know
oh yeah by the way we built this last
night this thing goes over the tent and
it kind of makes it super super dark so
then Luca is nice and comfortable he's
used to sleeping in the pitch black
darkness in his room so that's why I
brought this we didn't bring the layered
this this is the hotels but because of
the fact that we got in so late and this
kid was just wide awake we ended up just
end up like sleeping having him sleep in
the bed with us because this kid did not
fall asleep until three o'clock in the
morning like I said before so we didn't
even use the tent like this this
blackout tent we didn't even use it but
tonight boy me and you we're gonna take
a bath right now and we're gonna wind
down and relax and get you sleeping in
your space now because last night was
stressful having him in the bed this kid
likes to toss and turn so much whenever
he's on the bed with us because in the
early mornings after like he'll wake up
like at 5 30 or 6 sometimes but now it's
usually like seven and we'll bring him
over to the bed with us in the morning
and so he'll just like toss and turn and
there has been on one occasion where
Casey was so tired and he was so asleep
that Luca like climbed over his body and
he fell off the bed before so last night
was so stressful because this is also a
queen bed we're now used to a King in
our home so we have more space but still
like the fact that you know it was such
a tight space Casey's on the other side
Lucas tossing and turning he's not used
to sleeping with us throughout the night
so I was like every hour I think I was
waking up and like okay this look okay
is he like he hasn't fallen off the bed
right like I just I did not get good
sleep so anyway we're gonna take a bath
call it a night we'll see you guys
tomorrow actually before I see you guys
tomorrow let me show you the room
service that came in after we we took
our bath oh baby eating your dinner
we got some chicken tenders I already
cut one up he's already eaten the whole
one
yeah
and look how cute this is they cut the
watermelon in the Mickey Mickey shape
that's so cute yeah I look red I am so
sleepy so tired it's already like 10
something like how to wake up like at
five in the morning tomorrow uh Casey
and Isaac are still in the park and they
are crazy they're still like well it's
mainly Isaac Isaac is still trying to
ride a whole bunch of rides
a boy has all the energy in the world so
do you too
your brother are so alike you're just
demanding from your parents oh more I'm
sorry more see good morning top of the
morning to ya 6 a.m we are starting
really early this morning and we're
heading over we're like speeding through
downtown Disney because we're supposed
to meet 6 15 at 6 20. yeah we're already
late beginning of day three here we go
we are here before the sun rises oh my
goodness
early morning
you ready Isaac yeah baby is awake
technically but I'm trying to put him
back to sleep because it's way too early
for him
good morning we're walking into the park
I can't believe we're here before
Sunrise like that's really cool but also
kind of brutal because you guys know
last night it was a late night you guys
hear that they're doing a New Orleans
Mardi Gras thing for us we get the whole
New Orleans Square for a private party
like a private Mardi Gras party
[Music]
oh
this is amazing look at the castle it's
so pretty we're doing a Mardi Gras big
band parade down Main Street this is so
cool all right so we've never been to
Disneyland as late as the first night we
were here we've also never been to
Disneyland as early as we have been
today we're literally here before the
sun this morning in particular it's a
great way to start the day we're just
missing some Beignets to dunk in some
coffee
we get breakfast
what an experience baby I know the rides
are open too oh we got some Mickey shape
videos how cute we got Luca oh wait now
good morning
no no you bite it
wow
[Music]
it's snowing good morning
Halloween
[Music]
we're entering the Haunted Mansion
Haunted Mansion
what are you looking at Baby you see he
remembers because we got on this ride
already
is this haunted room actually stretching
all right so now we're waiting in the
line for Indiana Jones it was so cool
because we were literally waiting right
uh near where we were having breakfast
for them to do the Rope drop and as soon
as they did the road drop like a lot of
people came in like it was crazy it was
literally like a stampede of people so
uh Casey had to go to the restroom so
they're being Isaac are like get in the
line get in the line but then they don't
let you wait in line with babies I had
to like wait out there for Casey to come
out let's try to scare the kids anyway
Casey you met up with us we got in my
now we're waiting fingers crossed that
it doesn't break down on us is it
because it literally broke down on them
twice yesterday
all right
[Music]
lights on
that was weird
Isaac is taking his little brother back
to Little Town room so Casey and I are
gonna go we have a rider switch for
Indiana Jones and Isaac didn't want to
ride it again so he was like you know
what I'll just take my baby brother back
to the hotel room while you and Dad ride
it because we were planning on going
back to the hotel room after writing
because he's rides anyway but so cute
he's such a good big brother I'm so
proud of him he's become the uh the
babysitter after all because everyone
jokes about him like oh is he
babysitting here yeah it's true no no
they always say oh cool you got a
built-in babysitter we always say like
no we don't because we never push Luca
on Isaac like we always accept with open
arms anytime he does want to be helpful
like right now he actually volunteered
to go to the hotel with Luca so that's
so sweet so yeah I guess he he is being
a babysitter right now but Luke is
sleeping so he has an easy job he
doesn't have to do much so we're just
gonna do this ride really fast and then
meet up with them all right so we're
back from the hotel Luca's awake and fed
and now we're walking through Star Wars
launch bay to go check out a very
exclusive thing it's really really
exciting we're gonna check out the
Disney Vacation Club Lounge experience
follow the purple carpets
oh
wow
this is cute oh there's popcorn
[Music]
every Vacation Club cookies so cute
because I got myself some popcorn this
is really good oh more cookies over
there look at those Lounge
this is so cool all right we're leaving
the lounge and look a boy here loves the
stairs
oh
[Music]
yeah
good job my big boy good job
so proud of himself
all right let's get some food now we got
invited to this really cute Havana event
thing here really private we get to
check out their collection for the
Disney 100 and then look we got little
bites and then Luca here seeing all the
fancy food yeah I'm getting it all
asparagus yeah steak sandwich medium
rare yep yeah it's really cool we're
like in the Tomorrowland like next to
the Tomorrowland theater
this is Kyla and me I think it looks
delicious there's also lots of Rose girl
lobster rolls how cute the tiny little
lobster roll my voice is so hoarse from
all the screaming on the rides and stuff
I'm I couldn't really hear my sexy voice
coming out my voice is really really
raspy all right after that little event
party
about to do run away Railway or
something this is a brand new ride in
Toontown at Disneyland that we've been
wanting to ride here at least because we
did ride it back in Orlando and I
remember in Orlando it was way too loud
for a four month older I forgot how old
Luca was but he was a baby and then plus
Luca is like really really sensitive to
Cloud sounds he like cries immediately
so he's gonna wear his little earmuffs
yeah sweetie nice and ready uh-oh slowly
going down his eyes all right so he's
not gonna need earmuffs because Lucas
recently learned how to cover and plug
his own ears how cute is that it's the
cutest thing it's so cute and he really
did not like the earmuffs
[Music]
oh
hi baby
[Music]
he's dancing
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you are awesome
[Music]